на дибу панелі двері і ряд вони мочені
чи треба ваша і проект первинний шлях їх
2 до сильним за пропискою збоку сам не
диких європейських крейн на чому і будьте
ви винні кроки а сам політик
ми наступаємо азаза галина європейська
енергетичну за зовнішню політику не
менше наповнені отримати
енергонасичених більше такий кістки
джерел за крим від русі та допоможе влада
з Європи
дуріти з тасується з синтетичного
статевий енергона civic і можна вранці
ти святий на вугільних дерил енергії з
діоксиду в угличі
а також 3g на газі zedge а нами пам'ятають
проблема тут у тому і все бреше не міксини
бат уроки flash з поста ригов потім
приватним економічним проектом
а за турботи не наших партнерів то
друзі ps не ворог ховалася ціни чисто
економічний проект
вин матами масштабніше за
зовнішньополітичні на зливки
цьому ми рекомендуємо обварювати ці
харчування європейському контенту дивись
bodies of our напишу контекст та на вигляд
за розкол і вже 3 тени трубопроводу
спалю давно ясний казуальний сама так
ціни далекі мовчала я поважаю
альтернативний травня ми можна просто і нур
вати сум не ви наших партнерів
потрібно також у холод та інтереси
україни в похмуре ти мені правда я все ж
хочу сказати ще знайду і 70 років теми
при наші обожнювання ви добувати енергію
зірок навальних jarrell
ми продовжувати йому в коростово ти ас
багата навчання через видно побачили то
ядерної енергетики на більшій
мірі
і проти ембід штурвал від години нижче
поважалося раніше
цьому диверсифікація можемо від essense
олени на skoda нашим партнерам то
друзям консультацію та газифіковано
контент-аналізу чіп для первинного
потоку 2 так я за мету проекту я все
буде досягнуто консенсусу
на європейському рівні ви вже загадав і
праведного ні мечі на вигляд визирнув
наркотики сема і 100 тисяч 2038 уроку ви
народіть мучити взагалі за турботи не тим
що негайно буде
ви мишеня сподіватися більше газу в Росії
і я шви тарзан і покійний
у нас було традиційно добрі та нерви
економічний вид носа
російським союзом вони не з Росії
лише ніхто не може знати, що може
стати всі причини я за енергетичним
bespeco
замовлення забезпечується наївністю через
них дерил і нірвану сил
цьому я не поважаю провальним ти вчора
легко місія німецької у ряду
так ми мама досі той силою з містом без
зміни клімату олів'є khaleesi
ми з вини ви вирішуєте харчування ринками
методами
або в тему на премію потрібно протити
у європейському контексті
або наші найбільшої пророк він до ми
зрубали ним енергетично екології а в
голосі транспорту
вигоду тепла сійського спа вони не
впали на рішення праведно побачили в хату
дикаїна ти зажадав див від жуків
переконатися над тодоровою при тому що
платіть рулони потрібно c можна було ви
вирішіть за допомогою емісійних
сертифікате ви крем того
ЦВД далі і закладеності вид диких і
нірвана сейф не менше не за крима і
crane чагарники та ціни спрею по
приборкання клімату
анексія крима включення русел середні
україні санкцій за ходу діджей проти
комп'ютера Київ позиція путіна
завищується низовинну жакет продовжую
сантис нову знову наскільки правильно
на ваш кулі від політика нескінченних
продовжень сенсинг можемо сенс
придумати ще знову
він його складу мови на а то на тебе
тацю
leading відтепер я невелику альтернативу
максимум що можна вловити в цьому
випуску тип посилення санкцій
я хочу санкції не дають результатів
цієї ще можна зрубати легше
поселіть я абсолютний повернувся та
прибрати з Росії
думаю з
лоб на користь у всіх зачеплених турин
наприклад
розширення проти gallotti торгівлі
Путін саму свої промахи в бундестазі на
початку ми милого 10 лиття виступав за
створ аня зони вільної торгівлі
сьогодні така ідея абсолютно не
реалістично або треба думати і продавав
струкова перспективу як чопра чого ти
над розширенням спи прибрати і то це тема
може стати предметом а пані
нині ми стоїмо він a frozen нового витка
ядерне гонка оружня якусь нас правді рот
Сієна може вбити голод і з фінансової
точки зорі
там їй проблеми внутрішньої політики та
соціальні системи наприклад харчування
пансіонат забезпечення віку у зрозуміти а у
центрі у вас думаю ми по ви не завищувати
а після добрих ще до санкцій
а так уже досвідче нях ядерного оружня не
алтай самий джаз військового ти
цельсія через ікла dospěl проти
наприклад
за пропана вати російські квадраті це
і президентові говір усередину формат великої
we sing та ще п'ять зі старим овен стеллу
приводу малює сочі чоловіки лідерську
просити можна було б подумати і
пропав курок і війська сувені санкцій
Аліна так як це пропан порубає і тай-чи
найкращий німецький соціал-демократ так ви
молоді як аванс збоку заходу в
правді хотіла на вигляд тішить і велику
сімку
я як отже сам акули вид але син і у
складно не суть не спершу ремені
альтернатива ми не повинні daewoo ще вигляд
прямо van wezel є the deck
хвилі виникають проблеми на приклад
нібито по мені то це зу зустрічей
американську російського президента
залишилося від через дах догола
корчинської протоки
Оце могло до речі приводів готові ще
поговорити і проблеми один за одним
не розуміють шуму критичних ситуаціях
виду блять або дипломатії я завжди думав
що у вантажних ситуаціях не моя нічого
важливого кроку за діалог і 2 до того вас
жорстко критикували за 1000 висловила
peaches вибір чиєї компанії чому
тисячі пом'якшивши свою позицію висловив
а я по бою ще поки що крем у роті розряду
тануть їм годин рішення на новий значний
термін і ким є ваша столом
так крыму сьогодні його fet con su crema
only got one fine дат інтерфакс від він він
змінився я миколаївни пом'якше вал ідей
ціни проти рахунок погоди тис і с
дорученням росію міжнародного права
ми партія правова держави cts тусується
та міжнародного права людини ніж з
правді гіршому розрядку вона ескалації
tannoy складні shop це не я буду на
завершені та стадії процесу накладання
взаємо разу мене анни на його початку
c до світла якір повз і мощі зараз у
падіння зализані завис і на майданчик
процесу розрядки стояв і ельцинські
роки нібито туди на приклад і ставок
правда анексія балтійських держав
радіан ським союзом не розплакалася нашого
боці я до тих годинні рішення не було
зручного процесу розрядки тварин
договорі право оружня не жадібні
гласності перегудова то падіння
зализані завис та мрій щодо візових
акцепті від це аналогічно з ціни я б
радував розряду то крим
я котеджу сови і рішення не привід
живопису за нексію небесного ти їм і не
рубає про це не я на різьблений камінь
а-j inci харчування на проект від ситуація
на сході України
чий цьому яки питання побуту ним тому
ще травня на світі б ти путін та лізі
своїми ядерними ракетами середньої
дальності хочу доручити дайвер гіпс. пк
adsense канада і фага ми фа це шлях
мова харчування тому
відкривши нато поверніть посол Росії віджим
запасу дає знак готовності до діалогу та
злетілих харчів за цими можна було
б досягнуто прогресу для того
найчесніші підтиснення каже Єфремів обман
диктанта чимкент він дано така позиція з
причина через вкритий кубок України
раїса то
мусульман см3 по будеш ти ж у мене
складається вражіні чакри така розвинута
місяць на ритку травня внутрішній
політичний характер
там т ви вирішується харчування хто пірувати і
макро інше майбутньому
генштаб шпіца я міг навіщо цьому
договору про ракети середню там малу
адже дальності буде стрибок і даний
путін позбавляється і ти нас зустрічі за
холодних поки що мої номери нарощувати у
зброю їм чого я note with povestea так
самого Європи
група альфа штатний бонг мід віз stand
by за фрагів це з ноги досі ти по
разу мене руси youtube це нею можна
буду лише в результаті я ще у нас буде можна
вести ти на пари до нового краю світу ми
темних загальному
наша партія виступаючи за русь оружня
відображення розташування ядерного оружня
не ми ліберали
завжди прогнув ще смак віку не було
ядерне оружня фізіолог ти баба добоїм а
адже я дбає сьогодні вигода
утопічна
такому це за слово воїна Петро їм q1 до
діалогу тарус брови не можна буде до
ці ти владні яки години укладу не
посунула рішення над а я що буду відразу
мило з чим критичні ситуації вкрай
на ту сну у творити пари ти пошлеш and
life джефф будуть з ядерними ракетами
середньої дальності ши та шукай заслуги золя
q&a дня у 2019 уроки серце потрібно
восени а ти по новому вони так і ляжу
висимо 10 руки
може всі будуть ракети а може шукати
системи ми ж не хочеш йому повертатися
сяду логіці ти хоч шосе а там куточок
добрий бекон церква р-н ангела меркель
я кай чи треба моя великий сплив на
святу арені організувала mesh москвою та
вашингтоном і mesh залишив те
ісламабада чорний кал дипломатії він заєць
вершин маска він вашингтон
обидва а мені відомо відома що у Росії
є інтереси в галуті bespeco equis
тусується ядерному арсеналу китайської
народної республіки та аки на ворогів вони
у договорі про РСМД
я кай bull беллотто реально догляду теж
його доступний ком моста ти багата
сторонні долари
та яка на негайно травня боротися за
брата storony договори
з мама порожнечі пріоритетом для поні
мер collected назад у фонтану до
що такі didadu розміщення ядерних
ракет у не матч і не
я сказав у нас у ньому громаді вже
розміщення дерни вас броня алавіт
поведено
нов ракет нещасть на русі та на пиві
небудь і abayas кого основі я дерни
ракетні системи натомість у ньому екшен
їй inci технології aleksey v neck атака
потреба ви судите за все хоче садки
ти ми цим харчування і я не буду вугілля тис
а вид відповіді я хочу їжі ну і чоловік
вивести дати вид сік з проб ядерного
шантажу куди розбір tanya таких самих
систему у себе той день і машина по ви на
буде провести
су стрільну дискусію стива приводів 100
день ми не будемо гуляти і порада століття
вигляді ми нарубав атева і джаз і біля хвала
не
посунула рішення на там а років уже
знаходилася а назад цей годинник
дуже дякую панелі світ і дякую вам